le développement de la gymnastique au
port constitue l'un des plus beaux
exemples de réussite sportive sur le
plan local
étroitement liée à cette discipline la
famille maillot dont gisèle
professionnellement à l'urss assidus
dans la chorale anania ce chaque mardi
et ce tout est contestable chef de films
de toute une génération de gymnastes le
spj lequel président à se donner la
priorité à la pratique de la gym à tout
âge à tous niveaux
mais aussi allier l'éducation les études
à la réussite sportive
voilà en tout cas un exemplaire au credo
qu'elle a su insuffler dans son club et
compris à ses trois filles qui ont
inévitablement suivi un parcours tout
rafler les niveaux non puisque votre
future maman mais la pratique est en
cours l'année dernière
la seconde est témoin
passionné par sahel mais ferrer
l'équitation donc elle a eu droit quand
même à l'équitation parce que on peut
pas non plus imposé à dix empreintes qui
aurait pas envie mais l'a fait de la
gymnastique en a fait de la gymnastique
elle a fait les compétitions et on me
l'a fait quand même de l'équitation et
puis la dernière donc elle l'a fait de
la gymnastique avait un certain niveau
et puis elle s'est reconvertie à
l'aérobic et maintenant l'état l'équipe
de france d'aérobic
non sinon qu'elle est en équipe de
france d'aérobic et donc elle est à
paris elle fait ses études de
journalistes donc voilà devant
l'importance de la demande
on est arrivé à un moment donné où elle
a eu six cents 600 licenciés alors si ça
laisse un dossier géré six ans les 100
cède 1,7 dans cet espace était
impossible
alors la municipalité accompagné du
service des sports et puis non qui
pousseront derrière a décidé bon de
de créer un complexe alors au départ
c'était un complexe mouvements de
gymnastique et puis compte tenu de la
demande aux sportifs kane sur la ville a
préféré faire un grand complexe sportif
où il ya une salle polyvalente salle de
gymnastique
et comme nous on a quand même toutes les
tranches d'âge à la gymnastique
on commence à 18 mois et après on a les
femmes jusqu'à kehl et envie de faire du
sport ça me dit pas oui donc puisqu'on à
la section fitness et tout donc on avait
besoin d'un espace qui correspondent à
la demande donc on a un espace pour les
tout-petits l'espace pour la pratique de
la gymnastique qu'elle soit de loisirs
ou qu'elles soient de performance est à
dire pour aller vers le haut niveau
et puis après on a les femmes donc dans
les différents quartiers
donc on a un petit peu imprégné la ville
de la gymnastique parce que c'était un
besoin c'était une demande et c'était
surtout une demande par rapport au
public féminin qui trouvait pas tout à
fait son compte dans la politique
sportive parce que une fois que
l'enquêté le vol de performance le
handball loisir une maman le fait plus
ou moins
difficilement parce qu'un match peut pas
se déplacer qu'est ce que la gymnastique
au quotidien tous les soirs prendre une
petite heure sur son temps laissait les
enfants on va pas ça c'est encore
possible
alors c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place
toute cette structure donc bien sûr on
l'a pas fait tout seul on l'a fait
accompagner de la municipalité qui a mis
en place les éducateurs qui sont là
d'ailleurs tous nos éducateurs certains
ont été formés au club
d'autres sont venus de métropole parce
qu'il y avait donc une demande
importante et on a une petite salle
spécialisée alors si tu veux bien on va
aller là-bas parce que vous vous allez
voir on va les voir les tout-petits et
leurs mamans et parfois leur parcours il
ya des années d'être que la jeter à
l'eau les apartés de 18 mois à maman de
18 mois on les accueille
mais bien sûr il ya des conditions parce
que pour que pour qu'ils puissent
pratiquer en toute sécurité et puis qui
découvrent ce monde un peu austère un
peu difficile bien qu'on lit aménagé
pour rien il faut quand même qu'un
accompagnement des mamans et au fur et à
mesure il ya comme le sevrage du sein il
ya le sevrage à la gymnastique
progressivement d'un moment où le peuple
s'en vont et puis l'enfant à son
autonomie elle évolue et dans un monde
avec bien sûr un but personnel qualifié
parce que ça sarko est quand même bon
beaucoup de compétences est alors on a
des professionnels une professionnelle
qui managent cette section entouré de
bénévoles mais qui sont les institutrice
de maternelle des gens passionnés par la
gymnastique qui sont venus nous
accompagner dans cette discipline parce
qu'ils avaient un besoin
le postulat de l'association c'est je
viens l'association et je donne un peu
de mon temps
si chacun donne un peu de son temps on
arrive à apporter aux jeunes bon de
toutes conditions sociales
un petit peu de un petit moment de
plaisir lors pour nous ça c'est hyper
important et simple de la grande
philosophie de l'association
il faut qu'on vienne bon avec plaisir
donner son temps et donner
le meilleur pour les gamins quoique les
gamins qui a des capacités modeste
puisque en vain de s'exprimer à un bon
niveau et celui qui après à des
capacités au train qui peut évoluer au
plus haut niveau on a mis en place des
structures on a à peu près 300
tout-petits 300 points wii sur l'année
parce qu'il faut savoir quand même
prenait plus de 1100 licencié dans le
club on ennemi le 100 adhérents
alors ça va donc je dis bien du tout
petits jusqu'à la femme la femme adulte
et où la grand mère qui a envie de faire
un petit peu de tout net on est intégré
depuis outreau 80 nouvelles activités
pour les filles qui se lier big sportive
c'était dans l'air du temps la
fédération française l'a mis donc en
place et on l'a créé et donc tout ça
fait déjà d'autres enfants participent
au championnat de france avait des
jeunes et on a été l'année dernière ont
été selon jean-pierre de france avait
les moins de 13 ans donc on a deux
gymnastes en équipe de france on a là on
a à peu près tous les tout ce qui
pourrait intéresser les jeunes et
notamment les jeunes filles on a des
garçons bien sûr et puisque nos 1000
euros les abonnés
des reportages de filles que les garçons
ont su comprendre sans cesse de le
comprendre parce qu il ya des
sollicitations ailleurs par rapport au
foot dont les autorités il y en a un peu
moins peut-être pour les
pour les filles jeu
conseiller assure la détection mais ce
qui ce qu'on fait ce qu on a une école
de sports le mercredi mais donc live
c'est une gymnastique l'aîné gymnastique
généralistes c'est à dire il aborde tous
les agrès et toutes les sensations et
puis a fait au fur et à mesure on
perçoit les enfants qui ont quelques
aptitudes par exemple de force de
souplesse de détente à partir de
cette activité général et à ce moment là
on commence à les extraire et à un petit
peu les préparer autre chose et puis au
fur et à mesure suivant leurs aptitudes
et bien il
bon ils sont orientés soit sur la
gymnastique de haut niveau et à ce
moment là il rentre dans la structure de
haut niveau konami en place soit il
reste dans l'activité club mais ce qui
ne les empêche pas d'être
d'être retenu pour faire des
compétitions nationales au championnat
de france donc il ya il ya plusieurs
volets dans le la performance dans le
haut niveau un peu d'entraînement alors
seulement ses enfants c'est ces gens là
doivent revenir à peu près quatre heures
par semaine et les ceux qui en font
vraiment haut niveau font entre 15 et 18
heures par semaine
donc ça vaut présentement ça représente
pour venir s'entraîner tous les jours
ainsi que certains qui sont en classe
sport-étude puisqu'on a mis une classe
sport-étude en place avec une école
primaire et collège qui est à côté donc
ils viennent deux fois dans la matinée
deux fois par semaine dans la matinée
ils ont deux heures de préparation
physique le matin le mardi et le jeudi
c'est écrit dans des programmes alors ça
ça a été créé si tu veux dans
l'organisation générale du club on a mis
en place cette structure
parce que pour éviter que nos jeunes
gymnastes qui ont du talent parti trop
tôt qui te trouvent tous leur famille
donc nous on avait un souci c'était de
pouvoir leur apporter le haut niveau ici
localement et de pouvoir leur permettre
aussi d'intégrer plus tard ben comme les
frères casimir les équipes de france et
ainsi de suite
donc nous on préfère les conserver un
certain temps ici donc on a mis on a
fait l'aménagement comme il y en
métropole mais on l'a fait au niveau du
club ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est
fait sur le plan régional soit pour la
fée nous en interne
alors ici ici c'est donc notre salle de
réunion mais c'est surtout et
essentiellement la salle d'étude après
l'école et il arrive
madame la boutique irresponsable donc au
niveau du comité directeur de la section
gym études et qui suit donc le travail
scolaire qui est en relation avec les
entraîneurs et les établissements
scolaires donc
donc ils viennent après l'école ils font
les d'avoir parlé de voir se terminer et
contrôlés en a le droit de la
gymnastique et si les deux joueurs n'ont
pas été bien fait et si on ne prenait
pas contents du travail
on reste là d'accord on finit d'abord le
travail et après on fait la gymnastique
par exemple là ils vont partir au
championnat de france a sera pendant la
période scolaire leur pendant la période
scolaire
il faut trouver les moyens de faire les
devoirs pendant qu'on est absent de
suivre tout ça c'est donc ici nous on
envoi par fax sur le lieu où se trouvent
les deux voies
on suit il renvoie les devoirs donc
c'est un suivi c'est une lourde tâche
chaque année toutes les jeunes filles ou
les garçons qui portent en compétition
ont une tenue spécifique et pour les
prochaines compétitions alors pour les
prochaines compétitions on est en train
de créer le justaucorps des jeunes
filles les garçons leur tenue et puis la
tenue de plongée la fict comment
s'appelait lafitte mahi vols sas la
petite tenue du club que tout le monde
devant le petit jusqu'au corps de chez
les tout petits les automatismes mais
juste un peu
voilà ça c'est ça c'est la couleur du
club et on y tient parce que chaque fois
que la porte est loin en général c'est
une couleur qu'il en va très très bien
mais là on a quelques photos de nos
petits champions de france de notre gala
du 20e anniversaire avec donc voilà les
jeunes qui ont ensemble qui sont dans
les équipes de france dont anne sophie
en de l'air qui a erré casimir et
caroline mailloux et olivier salvan donc
on a quatre jeunes qui sont dans les
équipes de france et nous ont laissé
quand on veut en métropole d'avoir des
relations avec des clubs où on peut
aussi aller en famille de façon nous on
à mort les gamins amène les produits en
échange les gamins goûte la cuisine
rencontrent leurs camarades
métropolitaine ça c'est pour nous aussi
important parce que ça fait partie
ça fait partie de l'éducation de ces
jeunes qu'on amène et à qui on aimerait
un culte et le principe de la mobilité
mais de la mobilité intelligente j'avais
dit c'est parce qu'il faut aller il faut
les connaître les autres savent où
l'esprit donc c'est l'option les
préparer si demain ils doivent aller
faire des études en métropole
ils sont pas déboussolés ils savent où
ils vont il savait prendre le métro et
ils savent tout ça parce que chaque fois
qu'on va faire un voyage quand il ya
quelques années petit c'est le baptême
du feu premier voyage en avion
le premier découverte de paris première
découverte du métro on apprend à acheter
les titres on apprend le même on en
apprend à lire par exemple quand on a
commencé au niveau de l'association ici
on était tout à fait modeste moi c'est
qu'on a commencé à se dire il faut être
représentatifs au plus haut niveau
national
on a été au niveau national mais comment
représentatif à un bon niveau
parce qu'il faut montrer ce qui est bien
donc on entraîne nécessairement les gens
qui veut le à la perfection enfin à
toujours faire mieux
donc c'est ça qui est intéressant dans
le milieu associatif et de se dire qu'on
a réussi le parcours d'un jeune on a
réussi
d'amener des gens qui n'auraient jamais
pratiqué à une pratique bon mais ça ça
ça fait pas tout seul je veux dire c'est
pas c'est pas mon mon activité c'est
l'activité que j'ai fait avec les autres
et c'est pour ça que c'est riche et là
c'est pour ça que je dis que il faut
observer partagé oui oui moi je moi je
dis qu'on peut pas dire il y en avait
rien faire seul donc on l'a toujours
fait on l'a fait en famille au départ et
puis après de cette famille elle s'est
élargie et puis on a fait nos amis et
puis ce sont nos amis à la gymnastique
donc on en a dans toute la france on a
un étranger parce que on accueilli parce
qu'on s'est enrichi les uns les autres
donc ça fait ça fait un tissu d'amitié
qui est extraordinaire et donc moi je
trouve que c'est ça qui est intéressant